savoir les mouvements qui ont clappé était si
mécontent de Queen e8 qu'il a estimé que c'était une
erreur critique est-ce que le champion montre
son opinion sur ce mouvement a fait xh6
il n'a donc pas vu ce film je n'ai pas
calculé de nouveau comme ça il devrait il
devrait  un je t'ai vu jouer très
rapidement comme tu veux l'appeler
c'est tellement surpris de savoir pourquoi ça gagne
parce que j'ai sept pièces
attaquées deux évêques pour la nuit deux chambres
et des livres et est détective reine il a
quelques pièces protégées d'accord règle deux
pions et  visuel et peut-être que la reine d'accord, nous
pouvons changer, vous savez que c'est
un changement liquide égal, j'en change un attaquant
pacifique un appel de défense mais j'ai
assez de pièces pour le faire alors regardons la
nuit disons six mots histoire personne ne
sait pourquoi n'a-t-il pas pris  ok s'il
prend ici c'est très bien j'ai pris Knight
prend d6 maintenant je peux vous montrer de nombreuses
bonnes façons intéressantes numéro un s'il
essaie de s'échapper avec lui Queen d7 ai-je
mis coogee fall signifie s'il prend ici
alors Bishop prend thi  s sept huit donc
Bishop prend Bishop prend Queen
prend c'est magnat si elle prend si cela prend
vos reines oh attendez si bien alors vérifiez
et il ne peut pas à cause du chèque
et c'est faire tourner la goupille des pions et le
roi J est incroyable plusieurs mouvements  Évêque
âgé de sept ans Évêque d6 inclinaison huit
si elle prend ma reine alors c'est très
bien la combinaison
vérifie le seul chèque s'enregistre en donne sept
Évêque d6 vérifie en GA LMS Évêque de cinq
visuel soit six dans les jours visuels si je
vérifie et le visuel prend sept et  donc
vous avez un bel investissement qui est
un rock up suivez cette combinaison oui
et mais ce n'est pas la fin de l'
histoire en fait
cette ligne j'ai vu le tableau mais d'une manière ou d'une autre
mort trouvé après j'ai juste prouvé que
j'avais raison non cette position  tu pourrais aller
jumeau h50 jouer merde g5 tu ne peux pas prendre
ici parce que chevalier de sept check et
prends la reine si tu prends ici c'est
intéressant tu sais ni check check
anglais un caca XD 1 et C 3 ça a l'air
très bien pour black beca  utiliser c'est maintenant le
téléphone est fermé l'évêque est suspendu c2 est
menaçant mais soudain chevalier des sept
check em g8 l'évêque d6 C emmène B au rock
age 5 et il n'y a pas de défense merveilleux
accouplons à nouveau masse merveilleux
c'est refait donc vous avez eu le sentiment de
cette position je suppose et la finale
finale je peux vous montrer la finale si vous
sacrifiez la reine et juste dans cette
position si vous sacrifiez la reine en
jouant la reine prenez C 1 dans X 1 racine x
d6 alors j'ai joué la reine à coup sûr regardez
mate 93 nous avons besoin  pour check King J Bishop
prendre g7 tu devrais prendre la deuxième reine
g4 et aucune défense aucune corde ne peut défendre
car au Texas et c'est tout et
c'est fini toutes les pièces sont déconnectées
absolument et je n'ai pas besoin de côté carbone
mais il est tombé oh ça  est mauvais
il n'a pas pris le mien maintenant il était confiant
dans vos calculs ou dans votre sentiment
peut-être dans mes sentiments
on a juste essayé de fermer cet
évêque vous savez que ça va mais maintenant cet
évêque est une ville très forte alors tout d'
abord vous avez donné  un pi  ece maintenant vous
sacrifiez un autre P une autre pièce d'accord
elle a tué cet évêque mais cet évêque
maintenant il ne peut plus le fermer et il
vous a donné du Tempe qui est important
aux échecs oui absolument et j'ai ok
j'ai encore 6 pièces donc c76 au lieu de  7
ce n'est pas une grosse grosse perte non il n'y a pas de
poney mais un défenseur de moins comme vous l'avez dit
auparavant donc au lieu de 5 maintenant pour le défenseur
oui et il n'y a pas assez de gens avec l'
évêque CA essayant de jouer en
h4 check figures King Jared et simple
Roi h2 et pas de défense 95 95 puis
Dame bord
mate essaie de m'arrêter huit-six
taketake th deux très fort plus n'importe quel
mouvement violet que vous remarquez maintenant mon chevalier peut
aller parce que suspendu sans échec kun d5
Knight g5 obtient six à p8 maintenant je  avoir
cinq seulement cinq pièces en attaque mais vous
savez qu'il ne reste que trois accusés et il ne reste
que cinq très pazzo c'était 7-5 6-4 et
maintenant cinq trois cinq trois ans cinq
trois ans de toute façon la proportion
est toujours de cinq trois est beaucoup plus
dangereuse  t  han c'est l5 et par
exemple n'importe quel mouvement mais nous devrions être sept
ici alors il dit que j'ai la même
combinaison mais Nate immédiatement
immédiatement il a fait le seul mouvement juste
pour éviter le mat en trois mais de toute façon
c'est ici j'ai joué ce très gentil homme
qui prend  f6 c'est fantastique car
dans un championnat du monde, il est très
inhabituel d'avoir des sacrifices de reine
oui c'est vrai que la reine prend un contrôle f7 de six nuits
et ici c'est une
erreur impardonnable vous savez que vous partagez la
prise avec zéro ouais je sais mais je
voulais  prenez toutes ses pièces que vous connaissez du
tableau parce qu'après la tour prendre la série g
moi, ce serait peut-être comme lui juste en
supprimant leur propre XPS c'est d'un 97
et 227 Bishop prend un 7g ça va ici
échec et mat parce qu'il n'y a pas de carré pour le roi
et  il est accouplé avec l'évêque le
malheur que cet évêque pourrait bien j'ai
pris c'est la reine des sorciers avec l'
évêque et je pense que le reste est tout simplement
incroyable d'accord j'ai encore une promenade supplémentaire
nous sommes maintenant sur le point d'assister à l'
agari magique  cus bath
- le champion du monde vérifie ses calculs,
il est vraiment important d'être précis à
un moment comme celui-ci, il doit se
retenir clairement Kaz était très excité
ici
une dernière vérification
non le mouvement incroyable que la reine prend déteste
six sacrifier la reine les
contrôles de temps atteints et Kasparov  le capuchon d'objectif
enlevé vous marque à copier
et Karpov concède quel
jeu incroyable de Garry Kasparov